الانسان حال اهل لقاوه بغرب كردفان الذين
دفعهم تزعزع الامن للنزوح شرقا نحو معسكر
الميناء البري بكادوبلي
ابرز ما يقلقهم غياب ابنائهم عن التعليم
هنا يبحثون عن من يلبي رغباتهم ورغبات
اهلهم في العوده الى الديار عايشين والله
الحمد لله
ما فينا اي شيء الحمد لله لكن الوسيله
بنرجع بس بلدنا نحن من مدينه لنا اربع
شهور
اطفالنا والله كان تعبانين
من ناحيه التعليم ما لاقين تعليم وما
مرتاحين دايرين باي شكل كان نرجو نرجو
عشان يرجعوا المدارس بالرغم من رغبه اهل
لقاوه في العوده الى ديارهم الا ان
محليتكلي ترحب بهم مواطنين لقاهم واحنا
بنظلهم كمواطنين لمحل لجنوب كردفان ان شاء
الله واحنا ضيفناهم باعتبارهم جزء لا
يتجزا مننا وهم اهلنا ومرحباهم ان شاء
الله مخاوف النازحين متعدده شحوا الطعام
خصوصا والموارد عموما وهي تحديات تواجه
المعسكر والله الوضع في المعسكر يعني هو
كويس لكن الماسكار فاقدين الغذاء يعني لنا
شهرين
مفوضيه العون الانساني حريصه على معرفه
الوقائع على الارض لان الوضع تصعب سيطره
عليه استقبلنا عدد 1400 اسره سبعه
الفرد في يوم 13/10 اسره الاحداث القبليه
الاخيره في محليه الاقامه ويمكن تم تدخلات
واضحه وكبيره جدا جدا من الحكومه الولايه
ومنظمات الدوليه لا يزال الامل رفيق
النازحين هنا فقبل يومين فقط وهب الله
العالم هذه الطفله تهددها امها وتمنيها
لقاء لقاوه هي وبقيه الصغار في القريب
العاجل
الصعوبات التي يجدها النازحون في معسكر
المينا البري كثيره جدا
ابرزها بحثهم عن الغذاء وكذلك اطفال لا
يجدون مدارس ليتعلموا فيها
مواقف ومناظر انسانيه تستحق الاهتمام سالم
الهاشمي العربيه جنوب كردفان